Here are the things I prepped to make breakfast a lot easier
and quicker in the mornings.
Started off by prepping some bagels.
I made my dough earlier that morning and let it rise.
Once it was done,
I punched it to release all the air
and then form them into my little bagels.
While I was forming them,
I heated up some water and honey on the stove to drop them into
and boil them really quickly
before pulling them out and adding some toppings.
I pop those in the oven and got started on making some apple sauce.
I've been craving apple sauce so much lately and my kids love it.
Always have it on top of waffles or pancakes, so I made extra this week.
I also had some strawberries that I wanted to use up,
so I added those in as well.
I boiled my apples on the stove
with some water and sweetener until they were soft
and added in my strawberries before blending it up.
You can get it to whatever consistency you like.
At this point my bagels were done baking,
so I let them cool on my wire rack while I got started on making some
Savo waffles. These are gluten free and dairy free.
I started making them when I was struggling with eczema a lot,
so they've just become a staple in our house because they're so good
and I prefer them over normal waffles.
And to make a blueberry Compote every week,
so that's what I did today as well.
I let that cool and made some pickled onions and jalapenos.
I use my mandolin to slice them.
Added some smashed garlic,
my vinegar mixture, and also some chili flakes.
That good mix and set that aside.
Even loving breakfast potatoes
so I also wanted to add something savory.
I fried up some sausage and added broccolini to that,
and then fried up my potatoes and onions separately.
While that was going, I made a quick PICO.
Goes really well with the breakfast potatoes and sausage,
but also on some breakfast tacos.
I put that in little glass containers to cool off
and waited until they were cold enough to pop a lid on top.
But this is everything I prep.
I love having both sweet and savory options to grab in the morning.